(bright music)
- [Narrator] Have you ever
walked out of a building
on a sunny day and had an
uncontrollable urge to sneeze?
- Achoo.
- [Narrator] If you answered
yes, like me, you likely suffer
from a strange genetic
condition that has remained
unexplained by medical
science for millennia.
And if you answered no
you probably have no idea
what I'm talking about.
Sun sneezing, as it's more commonly known,
is a medical condition
called photic sneeze reflex.
- [Louis] Another name
that some have given is ...
- [Narrator] Hold on.
Before we get into all that,
this is Dr. Louis Ptacek,
a neurologist and a human geneticist
at the University of
California, San Francisco.
OK, go ahead.
- [Louis] Another name
that some have given
is autosomal dominant compelling
helio-ophthalmic outburst.
Or ACHOO syndrome.
But P.S.R. is really the appropriate name
that we should all use.
Photic sneeze reflex
is a tendency to sneeze
when suddenly exposed to bright light.
- Achoo.
- [Narrator] And as
strange as that may sound,
it's more common than you might think.
- [Louis] I estimate that
about one in 10 or 10 percent
of all people have this condition.
- Achoo.
- [Narrator] So a lot of us are affected.
But how and why it happens
is not fully understood.
Despite the fact that humans
have been pondering it
for thousands of years.
In 350 BC, Aristotle posed the question,
"Why does the heat of the
sun provoke sneezing?"
Aristotle was barking up
the wrong tree, though.
- [Louis] This doesn't
make sense because heat
in and of itself doesn't cause sneezing.
- [Narrator] Some 2,000
years later, the philosopher
Sir Francis Bacon also
tried to figure it out.
His theory was that light from the sun
caused your eyes to water, which
then seeped into your nose,
triggering a sneeze.
- Achoo.
- [Louis] It's an interesting thought,
but it doesn't make a lot of sense.
P.S.R. occurs almost instantaneously.
And it takes longer for
the tear ducts to react.
Furthermore, tears don't cause sneezing.
There's no evidence for that.
- [Narrator] So modern medicine
has come up with its own
theories, and it has to do
with the wiring in your head.
- [Louis] Sneezes are triggered typically
by irritating things in our nose.
And these are detected by a
nerve-the trigeminal nerve.
- [Narrator] And right next
door to the trigeminal nerve
is the optic nerve.
You may have heard of this one.
- [Louis] The optic nerve is
stimulated by bright light
and sends electric signals to the brain.
Some of that signal can be
picked up by the trigeminal nerve
and misinterpreted by the brain
as an irritation in the nose.
- [Narrator] Which triggers,
you guessed it, a sneeze.
Well, that's the theory anyway.
- [Louis] Photic sneeze
reflex is not a disease.
Consequently, the medical
community hasn't paid a whole lot
of attention to it.
Therefore, we know very
little about what causes it.
- [Narrator] But Dr. Ptacek
believes that understanding
P.S.R. could potentially shed some light
on more serious conditions.
- [Louis] Epileptic seizures
can be caused by strobing lights.
Migraine headache is
precipitated by light.
If we can understand what the mechanism
is that leads to P.S.R.
this may give insights into
other conditions, which
actually are medically important
and represent disorders.
- [Narrator] So, there you have it.
This 2,000-year-old medical mystery
may be worth solving after all.